why is godzilla in hong kong
that's one question that has bothered me
for quite some time now
like why specifically hong kong of all
cities
godzilla could have attacked tokyo or
new york or mumbai or
london for all the gas they are equally
large cities
well you might have seen breakdown
videos of other channels and our
previous theoretical topics that the big
g
is going after specifically the apex and
monarch bases
around the world and attacking in a
pattern and not in a random display of
power and destruction
well the answer might be very apparent
if you think about it why he is in
hong kong and it is on top of a mountain
peak that overlooks the city
in this upcoming movie godzilla would
make a comeback to the big screens
initially being perceived as the main
threat to humanity
and the apparent antagonist of the show
gom would be seen as the good guy the
solo wolf
the unwilling hero that has to make a
decision to stop the big bad
from causing more deaths and grief to
the world
but it is not as simple as that in the
previous tv spot we can hear madison
russell saying that godzilla has
left humanity in peace and that
something has provoked him
and dragged him back to war with the
world
and that is kind of true in the end it's
going to be humanity's folly that will
cause the two titans to face off to the
depth
the apex organization or industries is a
tech
giant that deals with cybernetics and
robotics
and also titan studies like a sister
organization to monarch but
more hardline and not that friendly to
the titans
as per the information gathered it seems
that they are the ones behind the
activation of ghidorah's brain cells
around the world in their research
stations and by doing that
their studies on the debt monster zero
has in fact sent a wrong biosignal to
godzilla
a signal that his moral enemy had been
revived
and godzilla is just doing the needful
and putting an end to the lingering
ghost of the three-headed dragon
so that is why godzilla had been hunting
and destroying all these bases
but again why hong kong it would seem
that the major scientific studies and
the main base of the apex
organization is in hong kong beneath the
city and in the mountain peak
that overlooks the city victorious peak
would be the main research station of
the giant tech industries
it would be here that he would receive
the strongest signals of the biosignal
emissions of ghidorah
coming from the mountain but unknown to
him
and the others it is also the place
where mecca godzilla is being assembled
i guess this mecca is made in china now
that we have
has to white godzilla's going back to
the place now we
have to ask how is kong going to be
there in the same place
and at the exact same time
so now we are going to the realm of the
educated guesses and the theoretical
sciences of monarch
and the monsters and whatever so
what we are thinking is that kong might
have recovered the battle axe by that
time
and has been trying to figure out along
with the humans as to how they would
re-emerge
to the surface i know this is kind of a
long shot but
hey we're dealing with a 400 foot tall
monster
and a 350 foot doll ape so i guess i'm
okay
so what i'm thinking is that there is
another apex base in hong kong city and
this one is on the ground
like really bumped in with extra
reinforced walls
and all that and it sits on top of a
hollow earth entry point
and this is where the scene of godzilla
shooting his atomic breath into the
ground connects
godzilla would use his power to break
through the barriers and actually cause
a riff
and his breath would in fact reach the
hollow earth from the surface
and this one adam windgut himself hinted
on this
so it could be true so yes as
godzilla destroys the underground base
and creates an opening
he would proceed then to destroy the
last apex base on top of the mountain
but at that moment kong and the heavs
the hollow earth
anti-gravity vehicles would come out of
the hole
and the big ape would confront godzilla
ready to take him down
believing that the g-man was the cause
of his ancestor's demise back in the
hollow earth
as he would learn about his powers and
then fueled with rage he would
find a strength to challenge the big j
so yeah
they would battle godzilla might win
with a small margin
a goal might nearly die or he would die
and
he is revived mechagodzilla nearly kills
godzilla
after being reactivated then gong enters
the fray they team up
and destroys the mecca and they go on
their own separate ways
so with that we come to the end of this
video do click the like button for
support and click that subscribe button
to be a part of this mind cue family
that bell button for regular updates on
your phones when we publish new videos
on monsters
godzilla vs context section videos and
other kaiju content
right here on mind cue take care fam